thirty so we are warzone rated 56
players rabid rating is 1850 time
handicap 30-minute tournament no
experience level required here we go
there are many others jumping in less
than 10 until kickoff five four three
two one let's see if I can chase some
people down
let's roll here Oh a tough one to start
mm Coco argh okay
Scotch in bit now what mainline
oh that's sneaky okay hang on hang on
what's the scoop now what's the scoop is
the Queen dead no she's not
let's back up wouldn't kick that night
away I am going to do this how are they
gonna Castle there's a fork right here
did you know that oh maybe not now
not so fast Oh Penner ooh ski for karu
ski trouble but Wayne I've lost games
before where uh-oh wait a second now I'm
gonna take it with check I have last
games before where what I was up to
pieces you remember that game you should
remember it it just happened it just
happened okay I have a nice cubbyhole
for my King if there's a check let's go
here anyhow get out of there night let's
simplify stuff it's the triple pawn
attack go for it
Queen trade give me this pawn and then
get my night right here hang on don't
fall for the tricky stuff where's the
tricky stuff for smothered mate a help
smothered me that's made on a g7 now
okay back to tournament 206 points
already starting with this
how do you start off with six points
like that you get two quick wins in okay
anyhow refocus you can do it you can do
it you can do it you can do it yes you
can here let's do this
I guess what's happening they're not
castled why did I do that let's come
back here and try it again
ah man let's try it again
is this working out just pawn takes it's
a free night it really is I'm not joking
around it really is it's a free night
until the bat move is played now it's
not a free night oh oh sure a ball for
Team white h2 happening again
h2 is on the cards h2 is delivering me
back to tournament land six who's on top
me but just by a hair there's a
three-way tie for first I'm getting
paired up with some strong heavy hitters
it was that redundant strong heavy
hitters each pond do your job
oh I just dropped a pond that's not a
good idea okay pond pushed our squares
come on push dark squares dark squares
f6 f6 Landing landing incoming the Queen
is close to cooked just okay I guess
take a knight and then play here oh he's
dead he's a dead man
I don't want to give him up maybe I
should have get out of there bishop okay
what why can't it be easier than this
okay light square weaknesses light
square weaknesses okay watch out for the
light squares okay this is a problem
pawn push I don't want to capture oh
what a pain okay just take them if you
really want to take give you the dark
squares would you please give me the
dark squares give a check 96
okay I'm okay with the B file or the C
file and let's not do that just yet I
would drop stuff do not drop stuff okay
where's that Queen going she's scaring
me
double up over here or is that really
the way to go no no I can't let you get
out of hand let's come over here my rook
is stupid over on h4 I really didn't
mean to do that okay maybe I did I gotta
come over here and defend okay I could
take that there's no takes right here
what's the time what's the time what's
the time keep track of time over here oh
it's very tight oh I got it I got the
Queen I should have gotten the Queen I
have the Queen oh the queen is dead
she's a cooked Queen cook tonight
they're gonna give a check and I can't
could flee okay what Wow oh they
resigned oh oh I thought it my clock ran
out of time there it didn't and I'm up
top they're 12 points 12 points there's
a tie for 12 but no there is no more
ties 16 okay war zone kings war zone
Kings JDP e for Bishop c4 f 4 9 f 3
castle Queen e1 Queen h4 f5 you
following along follow along these are
the moves very common ok this could be a
pain ok a little bit of a pain maybe
okay let's let's go here they're gonna
go clean site I guess and I'm also
playing here next right here
get out of there Knight okay let's open
it up what's this Knight doing I'm not
sure uh-oh oh that's a dead pawn this
pawn is pinned rook up and over look up
and over I really feel like just taking
that pun it's gonna happen soon I think
hang on Bishop you're good to me be good
to me
rook up and then over my queen is ready
to come out
Oh h6 is crumbling crumbling h6 uh main
- something real close one
- okay good back to chairman 26 okay
okay okay okay
what happened with the top guys somebody
fall back did somebody lose at 26
bloomenfeld okay let's let's do this oh
beware of this beware of this there is
no b3 because of here this is wedding
material will my opponent resign iron oh
wait I got the bishop deadly bishop
development develop your pieces take a
pawn give a check if the knight
recaptures let's grab this guy and then
play here break those uh central pawns
out and I just want to get castled okay
and now whoa make it one the Knights
gonna go here right try and get rid of
them though no it's not gonna be too
easy
ah what is my light-square bishop doing
he needs to do something else so does my
knight let's try this though can I
really still get rid of that night what
a stupid move that was by me oh that was
bad okay well can I find a way to lose
another game can I do that
let's go Knight d6 is falling okay let's
just trade a little bit make things a
little bit okay now we have a lot of
damage here we're doing damage gotta
watch out for the pig watch out for the
pig get into e7 pre-move free move
pre-move pre-move more premiums more
Primos
pre moves everywhere a lot of pre moves
can be played and rook up and over
first up and then over
it's close to a pre move rook defend
right here pins
let's go Knight give a check Wow I
didn't want to go there
Oh discover checks anything anything
just burned their time time burners time
burners back determine 38 38 33 28 okay
what's the scoop here can't can't lose
I'm playing against can't lose ah
are they just a Clark a clock burner Oh
what's going on here
can't lose is okay here we go
mmm I'm controlling f6 this is one of
the key ingredients to have that fishing
pole there goes my number one guy that
are trying to get rid of them
not anymore there might have been Bishop
a6 let Sutton's blow it open
uh-oh uh-oh
pieces are falling Knights dead this is
captured matin - threat check where's
the mate where is that mate where's the
mate please let this be made very very
soon check mmm check and then this next
one's mate yes ok back to term at 52 52
40 39 mm-hmm okay okay ah Lewan double
those points c5 for the win it's gonna
win d5 no matter what knight c6 Queen c7
Go Fish
and why'd I do that move ah they're
letting their clock tick quite a bit
they're thinking this one through these
are precious seconds gotta move like
much faster right all right if I
recapture my queen isn't there like a
bishop recapture and then I I have f7
falling pawn takes I might have to take
with my knight Bishop here e6 I guess
but there's going really slow here so 19
minutes and change left in the
tournament I guess I better pre move
that one if I could Wow
how many chances do you get to pre move
ecigs no matter what there we go ecigs
and castle I could play Bishop d6
because it's indirectly supported I can
still play Bishop d6 if Castle although
I don't know if I want to do that I
guess Knight c3 can be played let's get
out there go somewhere else tonight
and there they have zero time zero time
here this should be 7 Kings side castles
the plan actually it's not let me just
do this cuz it's gonna burn time even if
the night plays there in no time
no time anything there we go back to
tournament
6850 451 ok the big bad wolf
efore yes back to tournament land 77 Oh
got nine games in okay double the points
so far so good so far so good okay we're
gonna turn this again b3 we could see it
again or will we see it again okay now I
have a beefy Center beefy Center looking
for the beefy centers and actually
I'm still looking for it let's go these
bishops could be brutal absolutely
brutal I'm looking for right now setting
it up ah my number one guy is out of
there fine
take him ah man I really like that
Bishop I really like that Bishop and I
Castle 200 Bishop takes his maybe on in
some cases my knight coming over here no
I just dropped upon no I didn't
okay the knight could have taken there
okay I have to stop trying to go out
kill the king let me go in this
direction now this is an advantage over
here Queen right there whoa hang on my
Knights there to watch over it
forks that Queen needs to get out of
there I can't deal with that Queen oh oh
are you kidding me oh you're kidding me
I'm in trouble I'm really in trouble
there's something down here isn't there
please let it be okay
that Knight needs to go how much time I
don't have any time where is the time
time time time
I just want to trade Queens and then
everything's gonna be okay I got the
night I'm on g2 everything is pretty
everything's looking pretty now g2 g2 is
there okay checks checks everybody wants
to check
Mintos Dodger check give a check making
one threat hard to defend they were
being sneaky
that's me back to chairman 97 97 78 65
okay all right what are we gonna have in
this one more are the same more the same
at 4 9 f3 Castle Queenie one Queen g3 in
this case I want to be very cautious
about playing to h4 f5 next react to
that threat my bishops dead they can't
do anything about it but I still want to
make this move
let's try this one out it's not really
working though is it no not really
haha oh it's not really working and I
just dropped a pun
after all that or did I
okay maybe I should have sacked but I'm
gonna do play a little slower here oh
wait there's pawn takes pawn my queen
would have been dead meat
she would have been dead meat here oh
that was bad that was very bad gotta
watch out for g2 a knight right there is
pretty good there goes my bishop and my
night and okay gotta watch out for this
okay f6 no trades
don't you dare okay rook up and then
over Oh
okay everything's okay I have this
coverage Oh scary scary scary let's do
this is everything covered
oh it's very scary I have this rip move
I could come back with oh they missed it
like a block okay they missed that one
now no no no no no no no no looking for
a fork okay now this is dead okay let's
go Queen checks more checks hit a bishop
any move check move these puns move this
pawn oh no what did I do
oh wait oh I just let them get a queen
what am i doing oh they don't have any
time sorry for getting loud right there
it happens though why did I let that
pawn weasel down there back to
tournament that was stupid that PI and I
lost track of them he went into pac-man
mode I I looked away and he was gobbling
up everything
okay let's no I shouldn't have chopped
that I should have just played d5 kept
the tension keep the tension man keep
the tension
you know better okay I could get that
Bishop I'm not gonna take him though I
want to on do something else okay I'm
gonna do this okay give me the pawn my
queen is now going into pac-man mode
grab on see on the rookie rookie one oh
this is trouble big trouble kill a
knight give a check get the Queen
kill the knight land a fork where's the
mate let's try this I'll take that and
then
okay let's I guess we could do that in
between it
you take the knight i take your bishop
all right let's go with this so all
right well it's not gonna be a quick win
far from a quick win pawn push I guess
is available and my knight has to run
away scared
what's that did that was there peace on
b8 did I have a knight on b8 er - just
go there voluntarily no I just there
voluntarily oh man I was like I don't
know what they were thinking with that
one
they're just being sneaky or what 137
one 1899 and then we got 11 minutes and
change okay no oh oh oh oh okay gamba I
have to turn into game I just dropped
another pond I just dropped another pond
okay I could make a gambit out of this
can i I'm down to pawns though so
there's some fighting back needed okay
so let's do this because I'm not the
Queen
that's why yes back to turn they could
have took my queen but I would have been
would have been up on a minor piece
still nap three ah man we played last
tournament and we keep entering the same
a ball game where I keep throwing my
Knight to g4
it still happens and it never it never
gets taken oh they know it's coming
sneaky I'm still gonna do it
let's go night
take care I'm gonna what am I gonna do
okay
well I just dropped a pawn hahaha just
drop the pine I'm not gonna take it back
though no right here night you know you
want to play there or not okay he's got
to go I got to get control I want to I
up that H something square you know this
girl I'm talking about I want to get to
okay take me just take me please ah just
can't be easy okay I got to go for this
I don't have anything okay so now I
better save my night cuz he's really
gonna be dead
okay okay okay we're gonna trade my king
is gonna block eight and be happy about
that roll came to d6
I just dropped upon I don't want to
avoid IR I do want to avoid Bishop
exchanges might be a pawn push okay
let's go over here my bishop wants to
play on c2 put a question to it rook up
okay rook to be for no trades nineteen
seconds
get out of there Bishop I want to go to
be to next pivot square pivot square
trouble on a 200 I want to keep my rook
here okay Bishop do something
no no trades not yet at least
come on Bishop okay my Bishop is having
fun now it's having fun it's ready to
have fun give a check
rook block is bad
kill the pond they have no time they're
gonna give a check my king is gonna flee
towards the center they don't have any
time
pretty moves free moves okay back to
turn 177 138 eight minutes in change 138
132 is behind me this guy is up there
he's got 106 okay I guess we're gonna go
with this stuff okay get out there night
you need to go what does that light
square bishop gonna go okay oh I got an
in-betweener in between our check okay
okay
Knight checks Bishop checks I should
have trying to check here check here
check there check everywhere check here
check there hit a rook ooh
trouble I got the they got the exchange
resignation resignation back to term of
197 154 or 152 you know what I meant
Oh double the points someone's on my
heels Oh
okay let's roll here let's go okay I
have a center I do i okay what is that
cleanup to look at my pawns I don't know
what I'm doing with them really I want
to get that night out there you need to
go get out of there
Oh why'd I do that it's okay I'm not a
queen and structural damage can I get on
the B file why'd I do that I can't get
on the B file right now why aren't they
getting on the B file nothing best up I
should be laughing sorry about that they
should have went to the beef I think
they went in the wrong direction so my
rook is gonna play on the a file now and
get to this square because this pawn is
a tasty tasty pond right here on C file
go after the tasty pawns I should have
captured I should have done that why did
I do that
why is my king gone there that has
stupid right there over here I don't
really want that I'm what is going on my
bishop okay finally do something bishop
okay I have space more space hit this
pun that's the plan there we go got this
now right progress with my king next
this rook is stuck it's a stock rook and
there's very little pawn moves available
for Team white I'm double my bishops
gonna get on a different diagonal now I
don't want to move that pawn otherwise
the night gets this square the rook
still can't move oh let's come back here
now it's ready to rumble or not okay now
I get this pawn ah this is taking
forever I just want to take the knight
now okay let me advance but not so fast
maybe let me hit the knight first and
then here oh they missed it hang on they
might be sneaky with their h-bomb time
burners where the time burners King
position can't go there with check okay
they're looking for me me coming up real
soon
I'm not gonna take the pawn no otherwise
its stalemate otherwise it still man
okay back to Turman 217 178 five minutes
and change okay let's go let's go let's
go let's roll double those points
efore Knight c3 or otherwise a time
burnin
the game stakes have been doubled
Alekhine's defense four pawns attack see
400 pieces are getting kicked around now
the night goes to b6 f4 after d6 I play
Bishop e3 there's a big difference
between Bishop e3 and Knight to f3
what's going out at this Knight okay
this Knights ready to get kicked away I
should play b4 okay I'm doing now space
space space everywhere the knight has to
run home he's got to run home I want to
defend my rope cuz I wanted to support
this pond
this my rock is defended now and now
what can he do with this space advantage
develop oh I just dropped a bishop no I
didn't clean check I could block up my
bishop still with my knight our bishop
actually let's get the night out Bishop
out next to d3 it's a good spot right
here captured in this direction so I
have a half-open F file once I'm castled
I work myself into a pin okay I let the
light square Bishop out but that should
be alright I have f7 in mind okay here
it is coming up this bishop is watching
over that d4 pawn this is trouble Queen
h5 light square weaknesses bishop g6
stuff although the Queen is guarding
stuff laterally here we go pawn push is
available where is it
yeah it is ok the knight can't move
wherever it wants I'm on the bishop
uh-oh does that mean very close to me
clean block King here this is a killer
meetin one or two rook f7 they're down
on time back to chairman 237 198 197 192
have a lead three minutes and change if
I could get this one I think it's why'd
I do that again I keep doing that why
did I release the tension if I could get
this win I think I'll have it don't make
any stupid moves please don't make any
stupid moves okay so I mean this is a
solid setup but again I was looking for
something a bit crazier and it could
have come about if I would have just not
captured one reason for that is because
there isn't really much of an imbalance
and an ever so slight imbalance with
regard to the pawn structure but other
than that what else is going on I want
to get to f4 if I could get rid of the
dark square bishop I want to be able to
plant my knight on f4 or just do it like
that
get a piece might be resignation clock
burner tied with time tied with time
here and there's no resign Queen c7
Queens Queens
Kassel it might be Bishop here winning
the Queen what's the plan 24 23 22 21
just anything castle and I'm just gonna
pre move this I don't want my clock to
tick okay I got the Queen okay
I'm just gonna do that
any moves any moves do not let my clock
tick okay they're down on time back
determine 257 218 pretty sure I have it
let's see about that though
one minute 27 I'd have to win this game
in how how quick would I have to win
this game in order to win I can't do the
math right oh right away they're gonna
take my night okay wait a second
queenside castle I think I want bishop
in actually I'm gonna play h4 if they
they try to attack that Bishop let me do
it anyhow 95 coming up this pawn is
protected indirectly
get out there for follow-up Fork
it's a little scary over here without a
doubt oh I just dropped my queen oh the
queen is dead oh I gotta go here to
defend defend defend defend I'm on the
knight and the bishop they're gonna take
my knight first though or not okay that
got a little scary a little scary Fork
there's a fork here Forks everywhere I'm
on the rock take a rock okay I could do
that all righty I'm up a piece at the
end of this 21 seconds it's not gonna
finish it's not gonna finish I'm not
gonna be able to get just got to do
anything oh I'll just take that night
he's free free night six seconds I got
to go for quick mates I should have
given a check they're gonna give a check
to me move oh they're taking my rook
they're gonna make me finish this one
come on just call it there it is I'll
take the first place confetti I was
trying to get another one in there and
it was not happening oh man all right I
was the one being chased in that one
little bit off if he would have won one
more game he would have jumped right
ahead of me would have had to 58 uh-huh
that could have happened the games are
all right man